lovely to see you here on the carpet
Sophie now of course you've had a
fantastic season I'm sure you've got
another one to come we cannot wait but
if you had Joffrey right in front of you
now and you could say anything to him
what would you say and why you
definitely put well out but if it was
Jack in front of me I'd give him a big
hug because I love him I don't know yeah
you you would have to people out because
Joffrey is a horrible horrible person
honestly no recently you said that
Justin Bieber was like the 21st century
what do you think the similarities are
and why is that :
III more think it's the fact that Justin
Bieber was kind of adored by girls and
for me when I was younger I always was
like oh Justin Bieber I want to marry
him and then it works sorry then it
paralleled with Sansa and Joffrey
Baratheon he's naked like Tristan is not
like a psychopathic killer like Joffrey
is I just meant it like at the beginning
of the show when people adore him and
what do you think of Circe's character
what do you think Sansa really thinks
and what do you think of her I think
what starts that while Sansa hate Cersei
I mean she knows she's scheming she used
to look up to her and she just Cersei is
kind of the epitome of the fairy tale
you know not being true and Sansa hates
her for that for ruining her childhood
dreams and personally I love Cersei
she's like the coolest character on the
show I think she's got a great storyline
ahead of her she's crazy and is finally
if any of the characters on the show
could have their own reality TV show who
do you think it should be and why and
what would it involve well it definitely
shouldn't be John because he'd just be
like sad all the time
Tyrion and Bronn I think people have
already discussed this I've heard people
telling me that Tyrion and bronze should
have a reality not like the producers
don't get anything from this it was like
fans that were like Tara and bran would
be a great spin-off showing
you